the about turn by germany which has now
decided to send arms to ukraine led
swiftly to a change in the european
union position european union steps up
once more its support for ukraine and
the sanctions against the aggression
aggressor that is putin's russia
for the first time ever the european
union will finance the purchase and
delivery of weapons and other equipment
to a country that is under attack
this is a watershed moment
that just one of a series of new tough
measures announced by the eu targeting
not just russia but its key ally belarus
we will target the other aggressor of
this war lukashenka's regime
lukashenko's regime is complicit in the
vicious attack
against ukraine
so we will hit lukashenka's regime with
a new package of sanctions
the eu foreign ministers met later by
video link to formally endorse the new
measures that also ban russian media
outlets rt and sputnik from operating in
eu countries in recent days more and
more european countries have imposed
bans on russian planes entering their
airspace now an eu-wide ban is going to
be put in place the aim to further
isolate russia and the government of
vladimir putin
eu interior ministers have also been
meeting to deal with the growing refugee
crisis they fear the total number of
people fleeing their homes could grow to
seven million
james bays al jazeera brussels